Republican Senator Marco Rubio Florida
is a member of the Senate Intelligence
and Foreign Relations committees he's
with us from Capitol Hill after a late
night there for the State of the Union
senator good morning good to see you
let's dig right into the details the
immigration plan that the president laid
out last night he called it a down the
middle compromise but when he said that
a single immigrant can bring in
virtually unlimited numbers of distant
relatives that so-called chain migration
was he correct well it depends how you
define distant relatives they can't
bring in their aunts and uncles but they
can under current law bring your parents
but then you can bring your siblings and
understand that what the president is
asking for is he's asking for a change
that almost every other country in the
world now has by the way a change that
we had in the gang of eight bill in 2013
and that is to change family
reunification to the nuclear family in
essence a person who's in this country
can bring their their children and can
bring their obviously their spouse but
you can't be the one that brings your
parents or your siblings that doesn't
mean they can't come they just can't you
can't be claiming them to come almost
every country in the world has that
policy by the way well I noticed
yesterday that you tweeted that we need
a plan B bill that just deals with daca
and the border so do you think that
changes to this family migration and the
visa lottery can't get through the US
Senate I think they can because
Democrats have voted for him in the past
in 2013 in that bill the gang of eight
bill that you know some hate and others
always point to the Democrats not only
got rid not only went to that sort of
immigration on the family but they also
got rid of the the Visa Lottery which is
the other thing the president's asking
for now in fairness I think they would
say we did it as part of a comprehensive
package but but the truth of the matter
is that those things can be done I'm in
favor of doing them but I'm just saying
that if we can't if somehow we just
can't get those things done then we
should have a plan B that basically
focuses on border security and focuses
on making sure that the people here
under daca now do not lose their status
give them something permanent they know
they're gonna be here for the rest of
their lives and then fight another day
or keep working on the path to
citizenship since senator many people
took offense when he seemed to tie the
the dreamers to ms-13 gang members he
you know he introduced the family who
had lost two of their daughters
and he seemed to tie the two together
did that trouble you no I understand why
people get upset you know about that but
but in the end I'm not sure it's
justified that's like saying you know
you can't criticize the Mafia because
they're italian-american I mean the
bottom line is ms-13 is an evil
horrifying organization that's killing
and hurting people all over the country
of course the majority of immigrants are
not members of ms-13 in fact the
majority of them are not members of MS
thirds but he never said they were and
and my second point is the majority of
the victims of ms-13 happened to be from
immigrant families and immigrant
communities ms-13 does not go into
Beverly Hills ms-13 is in communities
where other immigrants are living and
that is who they prey on and that is who
they harm so when you're going after
ms-13 first and foremost you are going
after a gang that is hurting immigrants
so I understand that in this environment
people want to say that but I'm not sure
that's a fair criticism I really am NOT
okay senator let me ask you a question
about Puerto Rico the president
mentioned all the different places that
were hit by these storms but Puerto Rico
has had a tougher time of it there's a
lot of places that don't have power is
the executive branch doing enough to
make sure that Puerto Rico is going to
be able to recover well at this point we
need to pass a disaster relief package
and what the House passed was not enough
we have to do more we're working on
doing more I've talked about it
yesterday on the Senate floor with Bill
Nelson my colleague from Florida we've
offered a series of amendments and ideas
to make it even bigger and we feel you
know optimistic that we're going to be
able to get that done I would also say
that it's not just the federal
government there are also
responsibilities that lie in the
governments in Puerto Rico particularly
the government of Puerto Rico and and
and there are some issues there as well
so but I think my biggest concern is
that we did not respond at the federal
level rapidly enough and we didn't do
enough early in the process at the
federal level because we tried to treat
it like a conventional storm and it was
not but at this stage there are things
FEMA can do you know I've disagreed with
their decision but but what we can we
can do more senator before we go I know
that last weekend you flew back from
Florida to Washington to fire your chief
of staff after learning the day before
of allegations of improper conduct
is this do you think now a model for how
other lawmakers in Congress should
handle it when they learn someone on
their staff is accused of this type of
improper behavior well every obviously
every case is different and people
deserve the right to have accused to
present their side in this particular
case that the I was presented with
compelling and overwhelming evidence and
disputable
and that I needed to act on immediately
you have to act on it immediately once
you know something you cannot continue
to expose people on your staff to that
from that what travel to you about what
he did well the problem with discussing
details is it is and this is why the
victims and the people that came forward
do not want to be publicly identified
and I hope you understand what I'm about
to say if I say enough details about
this people will be able to figure out
who it is it's one of those kinds of
cases and so I'm gonna run out if they
ever decide to come forward publicly I
will support them 100% but but that's
not where they are I'm gonna honor it
because if I don't let me tell you what
happens then people will be afraid to
come forward because they don't want
that to be part of the search engine
results for the rest of their lives got
it all right senator Rubio thank you
very much